a publié nous ce qui est notre analyse
et notre analyse c'est que effectivement
l'hivernactine marge de manière
significative beaucoup mieux dans cet
échantillon peut-être qu'il y a qu'à
Marseille c'est comme ça dans cet
échantillon marche mieux qu'il est
hermétique voilà donc notre mais on
trouve en même temps parce que moi je
n'ai pas de religion thérapeutique
j'essaie de trouver ce qu'il y a de
mieux on trouve aussi que les gens qui
sont vaccinés parmi les la moitié chez
qui nous avions toutes les sur 15000
personnes sur qui nous avions toutes les
données meurent moins que ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés
et c'est bien parce que vous avez vous
avez mis l'extrait long déjà là parce
que la vidéo qui tourne sur Twitter elle
dure 10 secondes ou il dit juste ce
petit bout de phrase et on fait passer
Didier hall pour un charlatan qui change
qui n'a aucune conviction etc on va dire
je trouve ça ridicule que trois ans
après la guerre on en soit encore opposé
les antivacs et les provacs c'est bon
c'est terminé maintenant on s'en fout et
et il a le droit de dire ça tout le
monde a dit des conneries un jour ou
l'autre sur ce virus donc si on s'amuse
à sortir des archives il y a deux ans il
y a 3 ans mais c'est le tranquille et
c'est pas profondément malhonnête de
prendre des extraits sortis de leur
contexte
est-ce que la gugusse provacs peut
parler
du journaliste
parce que j'ai un peu la câbler moi je
trouve que c'est la première fois qu'on
l'entend si clairement dire malgré tout
que c'était mieux d'être vacciné que de
pas être vacciné excusez-moi il est venu
ici c'est vrai que je l'ai jamais trouvé
super clair il était toujours un peu
comme ça
Philon Dreux on comprenait pas trop il
allait à droite il allait à gauche là je
trouve que c'est très clair et après
quand on dit qu'il est antivax il est
pas anti-vax mais en revanche il a été
la sœur de figure de proue comme ça le
mentor de des antibacts donc oui à
chaque fois les gens disaient regardez
ce qui était contre le vaccin disait
regarde le professeur à où lui il a la
bonne solution il a le bon traitement et
tout ça donc moi je trouve que c'est
quand même malgré tout un signe
aujourd'hui d'intelligence et
d'ouverture d'esprit de reconnaître que
finalement le vaccin c'était pas si
catastrophique
il a dit que c'était bien là encore une
fois c'est couper son contexte beaucoup
de médecins ont reconnu c'était malgré
tout lui qui n'avait jamais dit qu'il
fallait se faire vacciner tu vois ce que
je veux dire la vie de responsabilité
beaucoup de médecins beaucoup de
médecins ont aussi parlé au bout de
trois semaines un mois il connaissait
même pas la maladie ils nous ont dit non
ça c'est pas grave ça c'est une grippe
ça ça va aller ça ça va aller mais
comment il a donné de l'espoir que ça
vous emmerde et je trouve bien non non
moi je suis pas propre je dis juste que
j'aime bien les gens j'aime bien les
gens
moi j'aime bien les gens qui disent à
l'époque je ne sais pas je pense juste
que ça s'assoit mais lui je ne sais pas
mais là c'est comme ça avec le recul
avec le recul il est en train de dire ça
Swan voilà c'est c'est
toujours basé sur des études
statistiques oui et là il dit je n'ai
jamais eu de religion je n'ai jamais eu
de non pas contre je n'ai jamais eu de
religion et c'est vous de dire en
honneur de se baser sur les analyses
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]